we want to talk about how to increase
the absorption of vitamin D it's not
just a matter of just taking more
vitamin D or just getting a little Sun
and there's other things that you can do
to increase the absorption because
vitamin D can greatly help with
inflammation with your mood with
insomnia with sleep apnea okay and
autoimmune type of conditions and skin
issues now one really simple thing you
can do is press on your breast bone this
bone right here the sternum and see if
there's any tenderness in there there
shouldn't be any tenderness in that bone
okay and then you can press on your shin
which is in the front part of your lower
leg and if there's pain like bone pain
that could be about a vitamin D deficiency
one really interesting thing I used to
do in my clinic is I would have people test
for that and then have them take some
vitamin d3 and wait for 30 minutes that
pain is gone completely gone so you
might want to try that it's just a real
simple way to see if you have a pretty
good vitamin D deficiency because one of
the big symptoms is bone pain not just
necessarily hip pain but when you press
on the bone it hurts
so vitamin D is an anti-inflammatory
first thing is are you getting enough
Sun get outside expose your body more to
the Sun if you have a mutation or a
genetic issue which a lot of people have
and they don't know it there's some
testing that you can get done on that
you seem to take more vitamin D to
create the effect because the vitamin D
receptor is blocked and so the vitamin D
doesn't absorb that well but you can
overcome that with higher amounts I did
create a video to talk about if you're
taking high dosages of vitamin D what
other things you must do to prevent for
other problems like with hypercalcemia
higher calcium in the blood there's a
whole series of things you can do I
created a video on that I'll put a link
down below but it might be a good thing
to watch that just because you want to
take vitamin k2 you may not want to take
calcium like dairy when you're taking
the vitamin D because we don't want to
increase more but calcium
in the blood if we're doing this type of
therapy but zinc helps absorption of
vitamin D vitamin A is really important
in vitamin D and this is why Cod liver
is so important because cod liver has a
nice balance 50/50 of vitamin A and
vitamin D with omega-3 which also helps
you absorb vitamin D so cod liver oil
has vitamin D vitamin A the two versions
of cacao mega 3 DHA and EPA so it's it's
really they all work together magnesium
helps you in the absorption of vitamin D
it also will help regulate calcium as
well vitamin D also can help absorb more
magnesium as well not just calcium in
the small intestine vitamin D is made
from cholesterol so if you go in a low
cholesterol diet or a low fat diet you
could starve off the raw material to
make vitamin D or even give you about a
minute so the cholesterol is in your
skin and your body then can convert it
from the Sun so we don't want to lower
cholesterol and by the way in certain
drugs that actually block vitamin D and
statin would be one of them because
statin blocks cholesterol show you about
how many levels plummet well guess what
you're going to get inflammation and
pain one of the big side effects from
statin is muscle pain probably because
also you're starving off the cholesterol
to make steroid hormones too and the
muscles kind of go downhill when you
take vitamin D you should take it wet
while you're eating some fat because
it'll be absorbed a little bit better
because it's a fat soluble vitamin if
you lower your stress you'll increase
the absorption of vitamin D because high
stress blocks the vitamin D probiotics
are important because they help to
recycle the bile from that's stored in
the gallbladder 95% of all the bile is
recycled over and over and over again so
it's a very efficient system and you
need the bile to extract vitamin D from
the food that you're eating
all right bile salts taking bile salts
when you're eating certain fats will
help the extraction of vitamin D from
your food intense exercise can help
increase the absorption of vitamin D
boron which is a trace mineral can help
vitamin D and help your bone formation
it also is good for increasing
testosterone vitamin k2 is really
important with d3 because they both work
together in the balancing out of calcium
if you don't have enough of k2 the
calcium tends to settle into the wrong
places the soft tissue like the arteries
vitamin D doesn't tell the calcium to go
anywhere it just increases it in the
blood and by the way it will lower your
blood pressure too but if you take k2
we'll take all that extra calcium and
drive it into the bone where it should
be and take it out of the joints and put
it into the bone but k2 is also really
really important in improving your
endurance when you exercise so it helps
the output of energy from the
mitochondria anyway here's a summary of
things you can do to increase the
absorption of vitamin D I'll see in the
next video
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it